Welcome everybody to the ace three
podcasts.
Soundboard experience.
Thank you to express Vpn,
quit and Siki for sponsoring today's
episode.
Today,
our guest is the wonderful and
illustrious wow.
Sean McLaughlin,
more popularly known as Jack Septic eye.
20 million subscribers.
Yep.
Then billing yet not so close though,
right?
It's like 9.9
I mean,
you just hit 20 million,
right?
Yeah,
like four days ago.
That's pretty insane.
Like 20 that's so fun.
I know.
And every time it's like you,
you hear the numbers go up and up and
up.
And then it was like,
I wrote it out to somebody in like 20
minutes as a lot of zero fucking weird.
I Dunno.
Why?
How does it mean?
Do you ever expect like,
okay,
it's going to slow down now?
Yeah.
I think everyone kind of expected.
They're like,
all right,
it's going to slow down.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would think.
Okay.
That's probably,
it never stopped.
Let's go on up there.
I don't know.
I don't want to have a wire tap it in
somewhere.
I have a secret upload button that gets
more subscribers or something.
I Dunno.
Damn.
That's crazy.
Um,
well,
anyway,
welcome to Los Angeles.
Thank you.
A good Irish boy.
Yeah.
I haven't burst into flames yet.
It's not yet.
It'll happen.
I mean,
you're,
I guess that's a joke about you being
pale I soon,
yes.
They're not that pill.
No,
it's not.
That bad situation is not that bad.
It's pretty fucking bad.
I mean,
my,
well yeah,
it's been here a long time where you
just fail.
I made,
while frank laid don't,
I mean,
look,
I don't leave the house.
You don't have to go in the sun out
here.
That's true.
I mean,
yeah.
And if he doesn't penetrate my roof,
that's,
that's the problem with La.
You go outside,
you die or you get stuck in traffic.
So,
uh,
by the way,
do you live in Ireland or do you live in
the UK?
Where do you live right now?
I lived in Ireland until last year,
then I moved to Brighton.
So I've been living there for a year
since May.
That's where pewter pilots,
right?
Yeah.
You guys,
you guys hang out.
You guys grab yours,
hang out,
make out all the time.
No,
it's weird cause we,
we live in the same town and he's like a
30 minute drive for me.
Oh yeah.
Almost never see each other.
30 minutes is like five minutes.
Best friends,
30 minutes and I'll talk to you.
So yeah,
we'll see.
She was like once a month maybe.
Yeah.
Although it's kind of close like 30
minutes.
That's pretty close.
Same time.
It's also like I'll see you next year
and then I've been doing tour stuff and
everything and he has his own stuff
that's going on so we never like find
the right time.
Why'd you move to a brighton?
Um,
I mean it was kind of moves.
I wanted to move anyway and I thought,
well why am I going to move to la?
That seems a bit far.
It's just a lot going on there.
I have a lot to figure out.
And I was like,
well I could have moved to London but
that's too hectic.
I don't really like London to live.
I was like,
oh Brighton.
I went to visit Felix and fell in love
with it.
Seems like a nice little spot.
Yeah.
It's literally out on the beach.
Nice and cozy.
People there are nice.
You go to the beach?
Not really because it's not a real
beach.
It's like a pebble goes all the time.
Yeah.
You never really have the weather while
La Kinda has the same problem.
It's like come to la for the beaches but
never go in it because of the water is
so cold all the time.
Have you been at the beach here in la?
No.
I pull it down off the beach.
Shit.
Yeah.
Don't bother about it so far away.
I don't want to,
don't worry about it.
Don't leave the house.
Don't go to the beach.
La is great.
Yeah,
it's lovely.
Make a lot of friends.
What brings you out to la?
Cause you came out here on an extended
trip,
right?
Like you're out here for a couple
months.
You kind of escaping a little bit.
Would you say getting out here and kind
of just,
hey my life you a little way of life.
I wanted to become a movie actor.
Really reach Hollywood.
No,
I was like,
I don't know too much shit.
Yeah.
That's how long it takes.
Four years.
I'll see you on TV somewhere.
I Dunno.
I kind of,
I've always wanted to come for a while
and every time I come here like we've
been trying to do this for a long time.
I remember when you started off you're
like,
you should do it.
Yeah.
That was in town for like a week and
nothing ever lined up ever.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
So it was like come for a month or two.
I have a visa for tour anyway when the
phone and abused that and stay here for
a while and hang out with friends for a
longer period of time.
And then it was supposed to be until
August and then tour leaves in August
and I was going to go back afterwards
and then my visa got extended so I can
technically stay here longer,
so nice.
Why not?
I don't need to be back home in Brighton
for anything anytime soon.
So just hang out here and do cool stuff.
But you,
I mean you've been talking a lot about
being burned out and taking a break from
your panel.
Is that kind of is coming out to la
almost like therapeutic kind of get away
from the life back there.
Yeah.
Which is weird cause I said that I
needed a break and I was getting burned
out and I just needed to figure out what
I wanted to do and everyone's was like,
La is not the place to go find yourself
out.
Disagree by the way.
Really I feel like La gets a bad rep.
Yeah.
I love that La is,
this is a huge metropolis,
one of the biggest,
I mean per square miles,
it's enormous.
There's so many different communities
and different you can be and do whatever
you want here.
I don't know why everyone has such a bad
perception of La la.
Yeah.
I don't know why I agree with doing well
anyway,
so,
but I mean you are in a sense kind of,
I mean you out here kind of just trying
to figure things out or is it more just,
you know,
coincidental.
Yeah,
what bit of both.
I was,
I was just got really miserable doing
the types of videos I was doing after
awhile.
It was like a whole month where I was
like,
this is crap.
Like I'm uploading Shit just for the
sake of uploading.
And I was so stringent on my schedule
and I was so proud of that schedule.
It was like,
I don't want to break that.
But your fans could they tell?
Yeah.
So that,
that was what made me do it cause they,
they started being able to see it and I
was like,
well if I'm not enjoying it,
you're not enjoying it.
What kind of comments would they say
where you were like,
oh shit.
Like maybe just like a,
I didn't seem happy.
I don't have the energy I normally had.
I looked sad,
I looked tired,
which I fully agreed with.
I was,
and then it just came to a point where
it's like,
okay,
yeah,
I need to,
and I was coming here anyways,
so I was like,
okay,
I'll on the way to la,
I'll just take a week off.
I've never ever taken any time off of
youtube and the five years I've been
doing it,
so I was like,
okay,
full break.
No Youtube,
no twitter,
no tumbler,
no instagram,
no none of that.
And I decided would just spend a week of
my own and it was great.
I got here and hung out with friends.
Completely changed my mind again.
You feeling better?
Oh,
100% I'm completely one 80 done where I
was.
You feeling like motivated to,
but are you,
are you afraid?
Like if you get back into it,
you almost fall back into it?
Because that was my problem was like
I've been through that same exact thing.
I mean I don't have a crazy upload
schedule like you were,
you were doing two videos the day for a
long time.
Five years,
but then you went,
you started doing one a day recently or,
yeah,
whenever I'd have to go out and tour or
something.
I kind of bump it down,
but it was still like,
can you still wore,
I'm still working.
I remember seeing you in New York a
couple,
couple of years ago.
[inaudible] 16 yeah,
it was a long ass time ago.
And,
and you and Felix and mark were there
and I was like,
you're like,
oh yeah,
we all made videos ahead of time and
they're all scheduled the upload.
I was like,
what?
I mean that's just fuck.
That's just twisted.
Like there's something fucked up about
this job in particular.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean to be fair,
my stuff is a lot easier to do than the
ones you did.
Yeah.
But still let's,
I mean you're still making two videos a
day.
Okay.
And you still under the same
expectation,
your fans have expectations,
you have expectations of yourself.
I mean our,
our approach is different,
but the consumption of time and the
expectation is the same.
Yeah.
I think that's fair.
But like this job seems particularly
fucked up,
right?
Like what is it about,
because everyone was talking about this
thing of like burnout,
right?
Youtube or burnout.
That's really big right now.
Everyone's so aware.
We haven't posted a video where we are
in the middle of burnout.
I would say for all,
I'm fully burnt out.
Like there's no wax left in the camp.
I'm new canvas.
I'm taking out a new candle.
I Dunno,
like handle smell like lavender jasmine.
No,
not those are the lavender is flowing in
it.
Um,
yeah.
I need a new essence.
What's going on?
Why?
Why is being a Youtuber so fucked up?
It's rolled psychopaths.
I Dunno.
I think it's because you started it
cause you love it and then it becomes
your job and then you have an audience
and people to take care of and you want
to do the best you can and it's just a
platform and a job that you,
you're not really allowed take time
allowed.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
Right.
But it's just not in your best interest
to do it.
And no one's,
you don't,
you're your own boss.
You make your own hours,
you make your own schedules and then
it's the curse I think.
Yeah.
And now it's just,
youtube is just in such a weird place
anyway with all the shit that's been
happening over the last year or two
years and now they're trying to
diversify their streams and everything.
So everyone just feels like on that
treadmill more than ever.
I think.
Right and then it's just coming to a
head and then one person talks about it.
It would sperms another person to talk
about it and then 10 other people start
talking about it on our,
everyone's able to talk about that.
I think part of the problem too,
I think everything you said is exactly
right.
It's like when you're your own boss and
when you're involved in something as,
yeah,
I mean I want to say toxic but that's
not specific.
It's just so like you're on the
treadmill,
you're on the hamster wheel and it just
like you got to keep the machine
rolling.
Yeah,
and the,
the mentalities on youtube have changed
a lot over the years.
Like three years ago at the gaming scene
was all collaborative all the time.
It was in your best interest to collab
with people in like beauty gurus and
everybody would be doing it to now no
one doesn't because everyone's afraid of
stepping on each other's toes.
Everyone wants to insulate their own
brand and build it as far as they can
and everything gets very,
I was self involved
I think I was going to say is that I
think now it's more competitive because
like,
I mean if you ask an average 10 year old
what their dream job is,
everyone wants to be a utuber.
Yeah.
And it's like so competitive and it's so
hard to become to,
you know,
earn a living on Youtube.
I'm a big youtuber that I think that's
part of what's so toxic.
Yeah.
About what it's become.
But you're definitely right.
I mean it's just not,
and we can all see each others.
We can't see what each other makes.
But if you make a certain amount of view
is like somebody else,
you kind of know what everybody's
makings or every youtuber kind of knows
what if your subs,
you can see your views,
you can see your like how interested
people that are the comments.
Everybody's just like,
well mine's better than yours.
And then if your yours isn't better than
than,
than you do some weird shit to try and
get it to be better than somebody else.
And it's a lot of like,
it's not,
it's not friendly rivalry anymore.
I don't think there's,
okay.
So if somebody uploads something,
you think it's cool so you like want to
do better.
Now it's a case of like I can fucking do
better than that and you try and shit
all over somebody else.
That's that.
That's what I feel like youtube at large
is now everyone's trying to be better
than each other in that way.
Okay.
I guess whatever came became popular,
you're like,
I swear I feel like I in some way has
played a role in that.
I do so because like I feel like when we
first started coming up popular on
Youtube,
it was from reaction videos and like
shitting on people and just like,
I mean,
you know,
choose your target wisely,
but like you,
you bay,
I mean our early videos,
we're just really shitting on people.
I mean,
and I think that we did collaborate with
people to know.
I know,
but like,
um,
I don't,
I'm not going to say that I'm like
wholly responsible for like this trend
of like cometary channels,
which are basically just solely,
almost talking shit on other creators.
But like,
it's definitely a fad that came up
around the time we started doing it.
We helped popularize it.
I can say it.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
Like you guys started off and you,
whatever way you perceive it,
but you picked your targets property,
you pick people that you felt like were
valid in criticism.
You're not shitting on someone.
That's just the entertainment factor of
it.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's a bit more embellished than it
would be,
but then like I said,
somebody else sees that and they want to
do something better and they want to do
something crazier and get more views
than you.
So then they end up just shitting on
people.
Yeah.
And then it becomes a thing.
It's like,
like,
like there's like,
I see this,
I see this a lot where it's just really
popular content on youtube right now is
like,
it's easy to shit on someone who's
being,
you know,
being creative.
And maybe it's not your style.
Maybe it's not a video like,
and so it's so,
it's so easy and people do this and
people love watching it being like,
this person's not funny.
Yeah.
And it's like,
wow,
they're making something original and
you're just fucking shitting on them for
that.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
Maybe I'm just,
my mentality is changing,
but I see that a lot on youtube and it's
like the people who are trying to be
creative and actually put themselves out
there,
it's so scary to put yourself out there
on Youtube these days and be authentic
and try to be creative and original
because there's so many fucking,
there's so many people waiting to just
eat you alive for as like you're not
doing anything wrong.
You might be unfunny and my opinion,
but like what do I have to flush her
trying,
yeah,
I'm going to shit on you for being an
unfunny.
Plus the youtube audiences have just
changed now.
It's like they all do that now.
Um,
it's very rare to have a community where
everyone is actually positive all the
time because you're not,
you're not an up and comer anymore.
It's not a new job to do anymore.
You're not the underdog anymore.
Everyone,
there's more money involved in youtube
now within the river husband,
and I think the audience are very keenly
aware of that and that they want to poke
at people because they feel like it's
easier to do.
It's like,
well,
they have money.
It's just a matter of,
if I say shit to them,
yeah.
It's like,
well,
we're still people at the end of the
day.
Oh,
I have.
I mean,
it's definitely a big part of it.
Anything,
yeah,
so it's just a whole bunch of building
blocks to where it is.
That makes a difference too on the
burnout because like you,
everybody,
even the people who talk shit on say
like,
oh,
this one's not funny.
That's all their videos.
They're going to be more stressed out
because they're afraid that they're
fucking coat.
They're know colleagues.
They're going to call them out for
fucking up and everybody's walking on
eggshells because it's just like a giant
mud slinging contest these days on,
I mean we went through a huge
spreadsheet of like drama and community
and reactions and everything.
Like that circle just went around and
around for like a whole year and then I
think that just fundamentally changed
everything after that Bro.
It's like communist Russia so that
chopping block good and get dragged out
in the middle of the night.
It's human nature.
Everyone wants to take down somebody
else.
Everyone wants to find the thing.
It's like I'm positive and energetic all
the time,
but some people think I have like some
weird seedy underbelly,
like I have like a weird peto ring or
something that I'm keeping secret that
they're like somebody waiting to find it
out.
Well that would explain why you're so
energetic and happy.
That's why I played happy wheels all
those years.
Never.
Everyone's just fucking waiting to find
that thing about,
I mean,
you get shit on Youtube,
right?
I mean a lot.
I think people love or hate you.
Right?
Would you agree with that?
Yeah.
Why do people like,
what is it do you think that people hate
about you?
I don't know.
It's cause it's,
whenever you watch my content,
I'm obviously very boisterous and very
loud and very energetic,
but some people either see that as
genuine interests in energy and
enthusiasm,
but to another person it's completely
obnoxious and that's like,
I completely understand that there's,
if I watched it,
I'd probably have some sort of like
thought process going on.
It is very,
yeah.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't hate anybody who doesn't like
what I do.
It's fine.
Does the hate bother you?
Does it ever get too,
it used to,
um,
because I,
I'm a person who wants to like make sure
everybody's okay.
I,
everyone's having a good time.
Um,
and I just wanted everybody to like,
have fun.
And then when somebody doesn't have fun,
you feel like it's your responsibility
to make them have fun button.
At this point I'm like,
okay,
you can't win everybody.
Yeah,
I'll just be happy.
I mean,
there's still 20 million people on the
channel.
That's a fucking very,
very happy with that.
Yeah.
You can't really say shit at certain
point when you have 20 million
subscribers.
Yeah.
I'm not in any sort of like egotistical
way,
but it's like clearly I've done
something.
Well people have some an understatement.
Yeah.
So I was like,
I'll,
I'll feed into that positive aspect of
the community rather than worrying about
what everybody else is going to say.
Do you ever feel like you don't get
enough credit in a way,
and let me,
let me explain because a lot of times
like people like you and mark computed
by who play,
people always say,
oh you just play video games and you're
so,
and you have so many,
so much,
you make so much money and you have so
many people who love you and watch you.
All you do is play video games.
But clearly there's more going on that
you feel like you don't get enough
credit when people say that too.
Yeah,
I'd say so.
I'd say that's fair cause it's,
what are they missing?
It's,
it's the whole aspect outside of what
you record.
Like recording it.
Game shore day after day.
That's an easy kind of thing to do.
You sit down and turn on the camera,
you record,
but you have to find the games,
you have to find stuff that people want
to see when it's daily,
everything like fluctuates so much and
you have to like be always kind of there
for your audience.
And I'm very heavily involved in my
audience and interacting with them.
So it's like after the video goes up
it's like,
well now I'm on social media and I'm
interacting with people that I'm making
sure everyone's okay and um,
re-blogging fine art.
I'm like tweeting out at people and
everything.
So it's,
it's a whole lot more than just sitting
down and recording the video and you see
a 20 minute video.
Like when I was recording what was the
sub Nautica,
it was like,
like sometimes it was an hour long
video,
but that was like a two and a half hour
session that's chopped down and that was
going out every single day.
So I was like sure.
And it's,
and it's isolated bubble.
It's an easy thing to do to play a game.
And react to it.
But to do it that consistently for that
long,
they never take a break.
I feel like just insane man hour.
Yeah.
So it's just like,
it's not hard to do.
It's hard to keep it up.
Yeah.
And I mean you,
you find your rhythm,
you get into your schedule.
I mean the thing is like,
yeah,
once you start seeing your channel
growing and you start making money,
it's like really motivating.
But you get used to that.
Yeah.
And,
and then it's like it's,
I dunno,
it's hard.
It's like you lose,
it's a thing,
especially with my channel,
cause it rose so quickly,
obviously plateaus out.
Every channel does.
It's healthy.
It's fine.
Yeah.
But some people went their channels
plateau with a freak out and they feel
like they have to do something else.
Cause no insane growth is no growth at
all to them.
Sure.
Especially when you're used to like,
yeah,
like this steroid injection.
So it's like you started off in,
everyone's like,
oh this is fun,
this is cool.
And then it's like,
oh well now I kind of get your gimmick.
I know what you are like,
what else can you do?
And that's the trap people can fall
into.
Cause then that's how you ended up
recording a dead body in a forest
somewhere because you feel like you have
to keep pushing this thing.
So you're,
you're saying that you were basically
just maintaining what made people like
you to begin with what's the right,
but your channel hasn't really slowed
down.
I mean it's not easy.
No,
it's not the center yourself and be
like,
what I'm doing is good enough and keep
doing it and just be stable.
Well that was always my mentality.
It was like,
sure.
It's easy to be like,
well,
if this keeps going,
I'll be a 10 million at this point.
But I mean,
no one knows what's going to happen.
So it was always a case of like,
okay,
these people are here now,
today.
So entertain them,
keep them happy,
be happy with them and do what you want.
If,
if you keep doing it,
obviously you're doing something right,
more people are going to come in.
I think that mentality of always like
looking ahead of like,
Ooh,
I could get this amount.
That's a very slippery slope to go down.
Most definitely.
Um,
you,
we didn't fucking real and we are
covering so much ground everybody and
let me hit them with one of these.
Remember we'll still here.
You followed the Roseanne thing.
Not that we need to get into it.
I just thought it just through twitter.
Have you heard this was and I love that
she actually say that.
Yeah.
I mean we thought a lot about it so I
don't want to get repetitive,
unheard channel that happened when I was
on tour.
They recommend and we all woke up in the
tour bus and looked at our twitter feeds
and going,
oh no.
Well this was from her apology video.
Oh,
good apology Rosa.
Yeah,
I mean Christ listen clearly a very
stable human being.
That was my first thought.
How do you like a touring you,
you do a lot of touring,
right?
I mean you didn't seem to be on this on
the road somewhat frequently.
Yeah.
We've got like two legs of the tour so
far.
It's the same show every time.
But we can segment it out.
No,
I love live shows.
It's like,
like create her an audience in the same
room together,
being able to do whatever the hell you
want and then entertaining.
I mean having that direct live feedback
is so much fun.
I think that was part of the burnout
setting.
Cause I did that and then I came back to
my video is alone in my bedroom.
It's like,
Oh man,
no one's here to listen right now.
And it kind of gets in your head is
small bits.
So I had to reconfigure my,
my brain.
Right.
I never said that word before in my life
that I'm fully on board with that.
What do you do in your show?
It's like a,
it's like a 90 minute standup show.
So it's like a comedy show.
Um,
sort of about my life and then talks
about my,
my childhood,
my teenage hood and my adulthood.
And so it's in three acts.
And then you talked about your childhood
and there's like good gaming memories
from my childhood.
So you get people up to play a game from
your childhood and then that's insane.
90 minutes single man.
Yeah,
Shell,
that's crazy.
And Games are all about experience and
overcoming your obstacles,
which life is about.
And then you move onto your next stage
of life and you just keep going.
And she told some funny stories from my
life,
I guess work.
Can people get tickets if they want to
catch you?
Are there tickets available still?
You sure can.
You can go to Jacksepticeye,
tour.com
to get your tickets now.
Get the word out there,
Sam.
Why not selfless promotion?
Not the eight.
Come on European tour dates.
Went on sale today.
Get your tickets to jazz show comedy
world tour.
Here's me life filled.
We've,
we've done one live show and it was like
an amazing experience.
It was so,
it was,
it was magical.
Honestly.
In a way.
It was so intense.
How many people were there?
It was like 200.
It was like a small,
I mean it wasn't a lot of people.
I mean you probably,
what size,
what size you do.
Uh,
it's,
it's between like 1500 to 2000,
which is where we have to invent new
sports,
like 600,
800 depending on where it is.
But yeah,
so we just,
we played a,
a comedy,
a store here in la.
Yeah.
Just to kind of test it out.
And I mean it was,
it was really amazing,
but it was just so much work and it was
like so stressful putting it together
because it was also live streamed.
We livestream is fit to go and set up
all the cameras and do all this shit.
And I was like,
man,
but you guys did all that comfortable.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I,
I work with the game grumps they have a
20 kilo,
they produced it for you.
So you very much just,
you're able to show up and just do your
thing.
So I just wrote the material and
practice it and ever,
how long it take you to rehearse it and
prep for,
for these weak,
you prepared it in a week.
Yeah.
But like how long to like memorize it
and rehearse it and shit.
I mean it,
I never really like fully wrote it down.
It is scripted,
but it's kind of just in my head as I go
through.
How long and then how long before you
did performed it?
A month I think.
And how was the first show?
Great Fun.
Touch the land.
And you didn't,
you didn't really rehearse it.
I mean I did in my head over and over
again,
but not like properly out loud,
like start to finish it.
How's the snow?
Don't do that shit.
Jesus Christ.
Fucking balloon animals.
Shit.
No stop.
How was your show evolve?
Because it's,
if it seems like if you'd just have it
in your head,
it seems like,
is every show very different?
I mean,
how does that Pan out?
The life stories are all the same and
the punchlines and everything are all
the same.
But there's enough like Improv Room in
between depending on the audience
because the audience don't,
don't know what it is and they don't
know what to expect or anything like
that.
So when you start telling the stories,
different jokes land with different
people.
So it's my farm.
And they're your fans.
They're,
they're good.
They're good.
They're very good crowd.
Yeah.
And this is what I'm saying,
like you guys did a live show.
Clearly your fans showed up to it.
Forgiving the barrier for entry is so
much easier.
You're not going into a cold room.
You don't have to prove yourself to,
I know they're very easy.
You should want to put it on a good show
when something,
you don't want to just get up and shit
on stage and have people cheer for you.
Well that's my next door.
Well,
right.
The shitting on stage just jerk off.
You're a cop on,
I call it circle jerking,
like get me a one vip.
Um,
but like when we do it,
it's the podcast,
right?
So it's different every time.
So the threat of bombing is,
is very much right there for me.
I'm bawling.
I'm bombing right now.
Do you,
do you think it's,
do you think it comes out of a fear of
your audience?
No,
I just think I'm an anxious,
well,
I'm just an anxious person,
but part of why I'm,
I'm going to get fucking therapy on your
ass right now.
Like we're,
where does your anxiety start and what
from,
like what,
what triggers it to like kicking bro.
Waking Up.
But the opening my eyes,
there must be some like trigger factor
to it.
Like you're afraid of not performing
well or letting someone down or well,
not being funny.
I mean,
Eh,
you know,
uh,
it was pretty stressful.
I don't know.
I haven't,
you know,
I need to,
do you think your audience are here just
to watch you be funny?
They're there to be entertained,
right?
You know?
Yeah.
To a certain point.
But yeah.
I mean,
huge numbers.
People showing up consistently.
They're here for your personalities more
than anything.
So what you're trying to tell me is that
me just being me,
she says,
I'll hang up and being off and now
you're telling me just being authentic
is enough.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's fucked up,
dude.
Oh yeah.
Sorry.
Youtube 2018 be fake.
No,
I'm kidding.
you're right.
I've just honestly,
I'm dude,
I got,
I got issues.
We all have issues,
man.
I have real youtube for a living.
I know I've always had really bad
anxiety.
I have,
I had like generalized anxiety disorder
in college that was like very,
very,
very difficult at that time and still
carry a lot of that weight with me.
I don't know.
I honestly haven't really ever sorted
out my issues.
Dude.
Do you go to therapy?
No.
Probably should I got issues back plug
years?
No,
it's fucking wonderful man.
You go to therapy?
I have started.
Yeah,
I've started for how long have you been
going?
I've gone to,
well I've gone to one so far,
but oh,
you're like,
uh,
I want to go like a whole bunch more in
there than here.
I have a bunch of friends who all swear
by it and have like,
so you've gone,
when did you,
when was your first session?
About a week ago.
Okay.
And uh,
did you guys have any breakthroughs or
what?
A little bit,
yeah,
really day one breakthrough.
Yeah.
Cause it's a lot about,
well I say,
I think maybe just the job we do,
they're this,
it's like talking a lot about balance
and that was kind of a lot of stuff I
came to terms with when I took a week
off,
I was like,
yeah,
that makes a mess.
And I was doing that.
I had never been anxious before in my
life.
And then in the last couple of months it
was like sitting down and all of a
sudden like,
this swell and your chest happens.
I'm like,
I like,
this is what the,
what's going on?
It's like,
I don't like this.
The best line ever heard an eighth and
eighth grade.
There's this great line.
She goes,
it's like,
you know,
before you get on the roller coaster and
then when you're done and you get off
and then it goes away.
But it's like you never get the relief
of getting,
being dumped.
The roller coaster.
That's how I feel all the time right
now.
You're anxious right now.
Right now.
I might that intimidating.
It's not,
well,
don't flatter yourself.
She beat you.
She,
she,
she has abuse.
Yeah,
it should blink into the camera if
you're unsafe.
All right,
let's take a quick break.
We've got a lot more to cover.
A lot more.
Good.
Let's get into it.
I'm very excited for the next topic,
so please guys,
do not go anywhere.
We will be right back with Shawn.
Make Laughlin your boy.
Yeah,
boy.
Oh God.
Ila.
You have to be a complete psychopath to
be browsing the Internet these days
without a vpn because everybody is going
to be checking up your skirt.
I'm talking about advertisers,
I'm talking about ISP,
I'm talking about the government.
They're all trying to look at your
privates,
right up the skirt and basically when
you don't have a Vpn Ila,
you're letting them do it.
Okay?
Your browsing history,
everything.
Even if you're not doing weird shit like
looking at Hentai online,
Ila,
you're going to want to protect your
privacy because who?
You don't want anyone having that data.
Express Vpn as easy as apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer,
phone or tablet.
You turn on express.
VPM protection only takes one click.
Express vpn secures and Anim and aises
and immunizes and Mennonite is your
Internet browsing.
By encrypting your data and hiding your
public Ip address,
you've got to protect yourself with
express vpn and it costs less than $7 a
month.
I'm talking about phones,
I'm talking about tablets,
I'm talking about desktop computers.
You don't want these crates having your
data.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Amazon's got this and like all
these advertising people,
they've got like a cloud of like,
oh,
I know when you're on your period.
I know when it's a Korean creepy and I
don't like these guys are the best.
Express vpm.
Protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get $3.
Sorry,
three months free.
I'd expressed vpn.com/h
street,
e x p r e s s v p n [inaudible] dot com
slash h three for three months free with
a one year package.
Go ahead and visit xrs,
vpn.com/h
three to learn more.
Protect yourself.
For Christ sakes is an internet condom.
Would you,
would you put your Dick in some sleazy
ass girl you just met at the bar?
No.
You put on a condom.
That's what express vpn is.
Strap up Ila.
Let's forget for a second about the
incredible vibrating features of Quip.
The incredible,
the fact that it tells you when he said
let's,
let's forget about it for a second.
Okay.
Because we all know the quip is a
incredible vibrating toothbrush that
tells you how long you need to brush and
when to switch sizes.
We all know that it's incredible for
that fact.
But here's what people don't know about
quip.
That I think I need to tell the bristle.
Okay.
Is the softest.
It's the best.
It's so gentle on my gums but it's so
strong on my teeth and I swear to God
I'm not blowing smoke.
I've tried every toothbrush under the
sun because I'm obsessed with oral
hygiene and my mouth doesn't come out
feeling as clean or as well taken care
of as this quip head cause it's got like
soft bristles and it's got rubber on the
outside and sometimes they'll go in
there with the toothbrush and it will be
too irritating on my gums.
And that you do not want to mess up your
gums because let me tell you folks,
those do not grow back tree your gums,
right?
And that's what quip for me is all
about.
Now we all know,
as I said,
that it vibrates.
It starts at $25 and it's pretty much
the god of toothbrushes.
Okay?
But what you don't know is how amazingly
clean and fresh your mouth is going to
feel after you use this fricking tooth.
Rosen,
I'm,
I'm telling you this.
I'm not,
this is the only toothbrush I'll ever
use because it's the best and it's just
that simple.
And the price is right guys.
It's quip.
If you haven't tried it,
try it now because your mouth fucking
stinks.
It's disgusting.
Your gums are receding,
your teeth are rotting out of your head.
Try this,
give it a shot and see if it don't
change everything for you.
I bet it will.
Quip
starts@justtwentyfivedollarsgotogetquip.com
slash
h
three
right
now.
You'll get your first refill pack free
with the quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack free at
get quit.
Doug ob slash age three spelled g t q u
I p.com/h
three thank you to [inaudible] for
sponsoring this video.
If you don't know what seagate is,
it is a ticket APP for live events,
which includes NBA concert post
Malone's,
whatever.
If they've got tickets and it's live,
see gigs got you covered.
Now,
here's what I like about seeking.
If you go their APP,
you've decided whatever seat you want to
buy the ticket for it,
you have the view from that seat.
You get a ranking one to 10 on each
ticket to let you know if you're getting
a good deal or bad deal.
Green is good.
Red,
my friends is bad.
Okay.
Now here is where you're going to lose
your shit because we've got the hookup.
If you use code h three h three you get
$20 off your first order.
That's just 20 bucks free.
There's no bs.
They're just saying,
hey,
you know what?
You want to go see a show?
You want to go see a live event?
Come do it with seeking trout,
our APP,
and we got 20 bucks off your ticket.
That's it,
dude.
They're just hooking you up.
Just click the me tab on the APP and
enter code h three h three for $20 off
your first purchase.
Click the link in the description to
download the APP.
I love seat Geek guys.
This offer is kind of insane.
Just $20 free to go see whatever show
you're thinking of because hey,
it's going to cost you 20 bucks more if
you don't use seeking,
so give it a shot and see if you like
it.
All right,
and you're going to love it and we're
back with Jack,
Septa Chi,
Shawn Mclaughlin.
That's me.
I like saying your last name.
You kind of looked at me when you said
we're back.
Like I was supposed to say something.
I really liked the hearse.
Something I really liked saying
Mclaughlin.
It's a fun.
It's like,
hmm.
What's,
what's Sarah McLaughlin?
Is She Irish?
Spelled the same name?
I don't know how that is.
Oh,
and the arms of an angel?
I don't know.
I thought for some reason that was
common knowledge.
No.
Okay.
Let's move.
Let's,
it's an Irish name.
Let's move quickly on this zone for a
little bit long.
How many other Mclaughlin's are there?
So you're,
you are close friends with markup
markiplier right?
Yeah.
You got it.
Make Long.
Got there.
How close are you guys?
Clothes?
Not as far as like the Internet thinks
we are.
I was just going to say how,
I mean like do you guys say you guys
have sleepovers?
No.
Okay.
Do you think we talk every single day?
Because what I was,
I,
I'm,
because the Internet is quite to the
contrary.
I'm out,
I'm gone.
There's this phenomenon on the Internet
that is completely baffled me is that
there's fan fiction.
Have you and mark having like explicit
Oh yeah.
Growth task.
Sexual encounter.
Pure sodomy.
I mean,
yeah,
absolutely.
Pure sodomy and worse.
Yeah.
Not there's anything wrong necessarily
with sodomy,
although thought of me.
So I mean when you say it's sodomy mean
it's like a violent act.
So it almost sounds like,
is there anything like rapey about
threatening,
let's just put it that way.
Right?
And because you can make love to
somebody asshole,
but like saw but sodomy.
But sodomy implies something like
nefarious.
Am I right or am I wrong?
Dan,
can you fact check the,
the definition of sodomy is sexual
intercourse involving anal or oral
copulation.
So you'd have a romantic sodomy.
We went from like anxiety and youtube
and depression to fucking sodomy.
Basically what we've just established is
that I could sodomized you romantically.
Yeah.
It doesn't sound good though.
Doesn't sodomy totally sodomized this
girl.
I saw them as though that over.
It was,
yeah.
No,
it doesn't sound,
it's just a style,
right?
It's a lifestyle.
It's a way of living.
Well Padilla,
I like the breadth of work is in sand.
Like this is just trying to show the
breadth here.
There's like just hundreds of fanfiction
here.
It's just endless.
What is going on here?
Well you know what,
hold on to that because again I think,
okay good.
It's gone well here.
No,
no,
no.
You're not just going to put up Niqab.
Very vulgar picture are,
you know,
but I want to read just to excerpt so
that the people at home can see what
we're working with.
You proud of me.
Mine.
I started made it.
It's not you.
You're not doing it.
It's an interesting phenomena though.
And I want to get into it.
Okay.
You don't have your own fan fictions.
Nobody wants to fuck me.
No,
nobody wants to fuck immediately.
seriously.
There's just like not at all.
Which is why this is so shocking.
I have like sex repellent.
Nobody wants to fuck me for better or
worse.
He was the only one in the world that
wants to fuck me and that's worked out.
What do you think it is?
What do you think people don't want to
have sexuality?
Cause I'm just like,
I'm physically grotesque.
I mean,
first of all,
that's pretty much,
I mean like,
you know,
not that easy to look at first of all.
Well like,
you know,
bodywise you'd nobody wants to fuck the
Pillsbury's doughboy for example.
I mean,
some soft song,
some people do,
but not the people that Russ Pillsbury
doughboy romantic sodomy,
mantic sodomy.
So anyway,
here,
let me just read an extra Mckenna to put
you through,
but there's just this one.
It's just so powerful.
I started the Rus.
I start thrusting,
matching his balance shades of Jack.
When I hear,
Oh mark,
I hit his prostate.
Good and hard candy.
Please hit that spot again.
Check practically screamed.
I hit his prostate again.
Again,
I jerked him off matching my thrust
daddy.
I'm close me to kitten.
I mean,
it's just a trip to the bay.
Yeah,
I mean I'm their kin.
I hit his prostate one more time before
he came in my hand.
Jesus,
not long after I released.
This is the last one,
so I'm not going to just let you know.
Not long after I released inside of my
pullout of him watching my seed.
Like these people that are sick seed run
down his thighs.
I admire my work.
Find Synonyms.
Seed.
Yeah,
like that's just sick.
Like damn seed.
You don't,
you don't get your baby seat out now.
And then I get it out,
but I don't necessarily call it seed
because that's just seems a little
fucked.
I watched,
I pulled out and wash my seed,
run down his thighs.
I admired my work before he attempted to
stand up,
but fall right back down on the couch.
Ouch.
Yeah,
it's going to hurt for a couple of days.
Like it was a fucking Jackson pollock on
his thigh.
He planted some cz fucking blame the
garden.
Yeah.
It's going to hurt for a couple of days.
I say chuckling,
getting up from the couch.
I get a wet rag and help him clean up,
but it's totally worth it.
He says smiling.
Hey Jack.
Yeah,
I love you.
I love you too.
So this shit isn't,
there's romantic sodomy.
Yeah,
the definitely very definition of,
um,
full circle.
So what's going on here?
Is this like a mean?
Yeah.
Is this like,
I mean by definition probably,
but like what,
am I joking though?
Or No,
no,
no.
A lot of this is not joking.
There's people who this is their sexual
fantasy is youtube.
Don't get who's creating these years?
Creating this fens.
But like who,
if you imagine somebody who wrote that,
what do they look like in your mind?
It's fucking George or Martin.
Yeah.
Hunkering over his typewriter.
That'd be great if he actually wrote us
off.
Fantastic.
He's the genius.
Find it.
Will you be upset if I pull up some art?
No.
Youtube might be,
no,
I pulled it.
I took out all the protest stuff a long
time ago.
This was,
this started getting very weird,
but we've been very vocal about,
oh,
some,
it's pretty wet.
Back to that one.
That one,
like,
as much as I don't want to do that with
mark.
Um,
that is fantastic artwork.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolute dedication.
Whoever drew that good art style.
Oh,
you're holding a cookie that you drop
once you embrace him.
Did you notice that are exchanging the
cookie interesting detail that they
would include a cookie and that this is
old green hair.
Oh,
little nipple pinch.
You know,
I had to do it to him.
Had to do it.
Got Him.
Damn endedness crazy.
But I'm sorry,
I'm sorry to put you through this.
I'm just like,
there's something like really special
here and that is just so incredible like
that.
This is a thing.
I mean the way I've always tried to see
it as that at first me and mark,
obviously good friends,
we got along very well.
Once you start doing stuff together and
you show that you have good chemistry
together,
like for let's plays and stuff,
this type of stuff I think is
inevitable.
Um,
damn.
I remember that one.
I'm getting the fuck.
I really looks like a mark like that.
They're good artists.
I got to stay with me.
Well your face is obstructed by
beautiful kissing motion.
Let me just cover it.
Let me just say,
Bro,
I'm,
I'm half Chubb Right now.
Damn.
Don't want me to make it a full job.
Difficult Pinch.
She wasn't no seed shit.
Oh that's all of them.
I know for the,
for the longest
time people used to do that.
Like we're like very heavily I me and
mark said Okay Septa pliers a thing,
we get it,
please don't do anything explicit with
it.
Cause it's weird.
It's not like characters from a book.
It's not like Jonathan Harris.
It was like people who actually know
each other and get along and have a
friendship and then they would do this
and then it Kinda,
it Kinda died down for a while and now
it's very open that we're not okay with
it.
The whole step supplier thing we're like
please don't very much like don't do
this.
Yeah.
Cause before it was like do it in like a
friendly bromance kind of thing.
But then people still kind of took it
further and further.
There's nowhere like just just don't do
it at all.
You get weird interactions in real life.
Cause I know you do your fence wood
fence and I was like,
did anyone like bring something that to
you?
People will yell stuff at us.
So like during some live shows,
if I talk about,
because there's a section in my life
show where he's talking about something
getting weird with like youtube
popularity and someone yelled out,
Septa player at me,
I was like,
no,
stop kids here.
Um,
but yeah,
every now and then somebody will say
something about it and it's still a
thing on the Internet and everything and
people would still do it.
And I don't want to take away from
people's,
if that's their outlet to create art and
that's how they really want to express
themselves.
I don't,
I hate being the person to take that
away from somebody.
But you personally via violated it seems
like,
but not violated.
It's just,
it's something that I don't think needs
to exist,
I think.
I think it went too far and like jumped
the shark too much and now it's like,
well you can't see it without seeing
that side of it anyway,
I think.
Right.
So I think that's why I'm Kinda like,
yeah,
just don't do it at all anymore.
Whenever anybody does something,
even if it's not explicit anymore,
people will shit all over them and get
bullied for and everything.
And I don't want that to happen.
Yeah.
Damn you can just draw us as friends so
I don't need to be kissing all the time.
Yeah.
Throw one of me and Ethan,
I be fucking so honored you have fan
fiction about sodomy fan art.
I just need this episode if you guys can
drop me.
Jack fucking I'm down.
I know about you but I doubt you have a,
you have a free pass and this one,
uh,
one saul,
don't worry,
it's not going to become a thing.
Nobody wants to see me naked bro.
You should draw Easton like super buff,
like just fucking ripped draw me as like
a big gay bear because Donna's big gay
hair,
beard,
beard with bdsm chain wearing flannel.
Nothing else man.
But yeah it did get weird cause then
anytime it got weird between me and
mark,
cause anytime we would hang out we'd be
afraid of even like a friend can be
natural.
If there's a photo of you guys being
like,
hey then all of a sudden all of these
little,
yeah cause we did like a pax panel and
we were playing cards against humanity
with Ken and Felix and it was some
moments where we like looked at each
other and like had like phone
interactions will actually think that
you guys,
do they think that it's real or do you
associate that people think that you
guys actually want it to be real but
like,
so they'll watch a video of you guys
interacting and they'll see a moment of
you guys like catching us in the back.
I knew that they,
and then there'll be like,
uh,
like they're just hiding there.
Bisexuality conspiracy.
It's like I miss that part straight.
Does that bother you?
And you both had earned relationship,
public relationships.
I mean it's not,
and then like it's just,
it keeps going and going and going.
Is that the part that bothers you that
people think there's a conspiracy that
you are mark are actually in a
relationship secretly?
No,
I don't know.
It's just,
it's just weird.
Yeah,
there's a whole lot to it that's been
going on for like four years.
So there's not enough time for the
talking back.
And you do need therapy?
Yeah,
absolutely.
With me.
The a little couples there separately,
they'd be like,
dude,
shut up together.
You guys definitely need therapy.
That's fucking weird.
Just the fact that we did that alone.
Yeah.
Um Damn.
It's fascinating stuff.
It's weird.
The Internet,
it's crazy place cause I don't see
fanfiction really about like on that
degree about anyone else online.
I don't know why it is that got you to
so field up.
Maybe it's just,
you know,
there's maybe there's a subsection of a
shared audience or something.
I don't know.
It's like tumbler thing.
Right.
I noticed you say you spend time on
Tumbler.
This is a tumbler phenomenon.
This couldn't exist anywhere else.
I don't know.
We'll see.
I'd like Tumbler Tumbler night.
Do you go on Tumbler?
I don't know what to do on Tumbler.
What do kids do on time?
What did you do want to come by told
dude,
you tumble Bruh.
Is where all the best fan or it comes
from?
My okay.
And everyone's like very engaged and
it's a,
it's an easy platform to like filter
through I think where it's like
everything else is typing in key word.
How do you browse tumbler?
What are you doing on Tumblr?
Search through.
You have like a tag,
same as anywhere else.
You just search through it and you see
people interacting with the stuff you've
uploaded that I just think of like
furries and like stuff like that.
Well that's the thing,
like that's,
that's definitely a side of timber and
anybody who's out in timber,
we will say the exact same thing and it
pops up.
You almost can't avoid it.
You're like,
hey flowers for mother's day,
here's a,
there's a brony taken it up the ass.
There's,
there's porn bots on Tumbler.
So you'd be going through that like your
regular self to be some fine arts,
some text posts,
everything.
And all of a sudden it's like a picture
of a woman in a bikini saying she wants
to have sex call her now.
Really?
It's just like,
wow,
okay.
I don't know this woman or a metabolic,
it's another ones like one lick.
My Pussy do it.
I'm like,
oh,
right,
sure.
Did you get her consent?
And what was really weird about it?
Because you can tell it's just like
instagram models or whatever and they're
just obviously bought.
So they find pictures that got
interaction or have semi-nudity or
whatever in it.
And then one time I was going down and
it was like a Jessica [inaudible]
picture.
I was like,
wanna fuck her,
do it.
And I was like,
wow,
that was weird.
Yeah.
So in like,
I know her actually the,
actually this is a problem I've heard
about is that like people who make porn
ads on
the Internet,
they'll just grab any photo.
Yeah.
Without any permission.
Because like,
Whoa,
who are you going to do about it?
So we'll grab a photo of a totally
wholesome pretty girl from instagram and
then put her on porn hub,
like fuck hoc,
local cuties or tinder.
They're like catnip to people with
somebody.
That is so great.
And that's gotta be an we know probably,
but it's like impossible to do anything
about it.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Damn.
I'm,
I got my tumblr account and I have no
access to it.
You're not tumbling.
I used to upload my art and I just
forgot my password one day and I,
it was my old email account and now I
just have no way to,
I mean tumbler is owned by Yahoo so it's
a fucking mess.
Yeah.
So they locked me out.
You ever tried to get back in and it was
going on,
tried your best to get you in.
You want to get back in and tumble?
Dude,
wait,
how could you,
is it linked to your yahoo account
through the night?
All the email,
which I don't have the password to.
You were just fuck your life.
Yeah.
It's called over healer.
Where are you going to catch your
Brownie for that?
Do you ever see anywhere part on Tumbler
on your time there?
I did see like a,
like randomly crawling.
I remember all of a sudden there was
born and I didn't even know where it
comes to is a problem.
Yeah.
That's an issue.
Tumbler get one.
It was so long ago.
I don't know if it's still the same.
Yeah.
I was like,
I think it's always going to be the
same.
There's no way of stopping it.
What?
You know,
again,
like the thing that I see on tumblers,
this furry porn.
Have you seen that?
Can I just say,
I'm really glad that the episode you
start talking about furry porn on minute
that I have to be on.
I mean,
do you want to participate in this
conversation?
We could skip,
oh,
we're in it.
We're in it.
Let's fuck.
Because like I,
that's the thing that I just,
I don't have the empathy as a human
being to understand.
I don't relate on an emotional base like
you,
what you have,
I don't know if you guys have ever seen
brony or furry porn,
but it's drawings of humanoid animals
with massive Cox.
I have never seen it come fest.
Just nasty.
Just don't get it.
Okay.
I don't let them explain this.
Itemize each other.
Okay.
Romantics,
Lisa.
But if their lives are not harming you,
okay.
You don't use tumbler but come holiday.
That's the stuff you do see on Tumbler.
Yeah,
yeah.
Fuck it all that.
Well,
I've used it to the extent where I'm
like,
all right,
all right.
Moroni downplay roney sodomy telling
you,
you don't have to fucking try that shit
on there.
You don't have to try.
All right,
look,
Jack is Mr inclusive.
He's going to stand up for fucking
everybody,
so I'm not even going to try to go.
I mean,
you're allowed to have your opinion.
I just,
I mean,
I don't see it,
so I was going to like,
I mean,
you're welcome to live your life and I'm
not,
I'm not going tell you don't.
But I also have one hand need to
acknowledge that that's fucking bizarre.
Like we can acknowledge like,
dude,
keep doing your thing.
Love what you're doing,
but also what the fuck?
Right.
Like we can build,
have both minds about it.
Right?
I guess you January,
whatever isn't part of the southern part
of the roadmap.
This isn't on your Flowchart,
you know?
But I mean,
if that's what you're into,
maybe that's what people think is,
does that mean you want to fuck animals?
No,
that's the,
that's the thing about it.
It's like there's so much like intricacy
to it.
It's like,
no,
I just want to fuck somebody else who's
dressed as an animal,
so don't want to fuck.
And because in the cartoons they are,
they're not dressed as animals are
animals.
Right.
And they have giant horse.
Cox did it.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
I mean,
if you're going to draw yourself,
you might as well draw yourself with the
giant horse cock,
but they're are also horses.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean,
I agree to me.
I don't get it.
Okay,
thank you.
I'm not,
I don't know why I don't.
I don't mind them.
I'm like holding you to this book.
Plug tail.
Yeah.
All right.
That's a fascinating thing.
I mean,
if you've never seen it,
go check it out on tumblr because it's
fucking wild ride.
It's a wild ride.
It's a count on Tumbler Brownie Aisley
Brownie experience on Tuesday.
We're doing an episode and I'm this week
I'm going to show you brony porn on
Tumbler and we'll report back on
Tuesday.
Okay,
great.
Please text me if you want to look and
call in if you want to call in.
I love to true.
I'll come back for a second episode of
the podcast to talk about our only
follows,
we make it like a book club.
Interesting stuff.
Really.
So,
um,
I love this or it's just so interesting
that,
I mean,
your,
your channel got its first big break
from a puny pipe contest.
Right?
That's an accurate statement.
Yeah.
I have this clip.
It's really short.
It's crazy that this is just the small
little shout out.
Okay.
Um,
oh,
you're actually going to show this shout
out.
Oh my God,
man.
I don't think it's embarrassing or
anything.
It's really short fucking,
I don't even know that he doesn't even,
he doesn't even show you.
He just said it.
Yeah.
Oh,
look at you in the corner.
That's me.
Almost unrecognizable.
Yeah.
Dance.
Sweet baby boy.
How old were you at this time?
Uh,
2013.
So five years ago.
Three mm hmm.
Cool.
Okay.
How about the mothering fucking dad?
I didn't even know.
This guy.
Seems crazy.
I really like that.
Whatever it is he's doing.
He seemed really funny.
His name is Jack Septic Eye.
You should check him out.
Check except the guy.
What?
What,
what was that like for you?
Well here's the thing cause there's huge
misconceptions about that because it's
easy.
Look back at me and Felix
are friends and everything.
I look back and say like,
oh that's how he became popular.
That's the secret.
You just get a shadow competition.
But at that time I was at 2.2
k subs there and then after that I came
home from college and it was at 15,000
subscribers,
which is fucking bananas at that moment.
And then after like three days and went
up to 20 k and then completely stopped,
nothing happened after that.
And Christine and I had been doing like
grand theft auto five videos twice a day
for like a week and no one was watching
those either.
So the people who came from the shout
out and kind of watch one video and it
got like 15 k views and then just didn't
watch anything else.
Everyone.
And then people just stop subscribing.
It went from like getting 3000 subs a
day to a hundred right.
And then it's like no one really watched
any more.
So that that was,
that was the moment where I changed like
everything I was doing and Tristan and
became more of myself and just like
settled into the content.
So how long after the shadow was it,
like what's the timeline of,
of the growth of your channel?
Like in comparison is how long did it,
how much time passed from that shadow to
the point where your channel started?
Like picking up traction?
About six months,
I'd say.
So it was after that,
that was September of 2013 and then
after that,
like the rest of the year passed and
nothing was really happening.
Some stuff was still like residual and
everything,
but I just like put my foot down.
I started doing videos like much harder,
much better,
a lot more variety.
I wasn't just doing the same game
anymore.
The whole top of the morning thing
became like a huge thing at that point.
And then it was August,
2014 that the channel hit a million
soaps.
So it was like right after that,
nothing really happened,
but it was the thing that instigated the
passion in me.
So it was like,
well,
here's this opportunity.
I thought it would make the channel huge
and then it kind of died out real quick.
And I was like,
okay,
well I need to do something I need to
like that's,
you know,
that is what,
that's the beautiful thing is anyone can
get a shadow.
Like it happens all the time,
but not everybody takes that.
Yeah.
And shout to,
into an opportunity to shout out alone
doesn't get you to no.
Yeah.
And Felix at 26 million subscribers at
that point,
fucking just dental is even back then.
He was like,
yeah,
so like five years later,
and I'm like six behind that.
And it's like if you told that kid that
that was going to happen,
he would've lost his fucking mind.
Um,
no,
but I think that that's the testimony.
It's easy to be like,
oh,
he got a shell from Pupae,
you know?
Of course he's got 20 million,
but like the shadow is literally,
it's just like a little like it's like
this.
Yeah,
the little,
it's important but like you have to
take,
and the analogy I always use is like
your channels,
your care.
Felix is the key.
Turning it on,
get you going,
teaches you how to like drive it or
whatever,
but you're the one who has to like
change gears and stay in lane and drive
down to the fly.
The way that shadow wasn't that ethic
either.
No,
it was like very lightweight.
If you go through,
there's a,
there's a couple of other channels who
he shouted out in that and there was
another channel called illmatic.
I remember who I thought was phenomenal
because of his editing at the time was
insane.
I think he's Australian and he got up to
like 11 key subs and then never went any
further.
I don't know what his channel was that
now I hope he's doing well.
He'll manic shut up but are getting a
shout out bro.
Shout out from shouting,
getting a fucking,
it's shout out all day.
I know what it was.
That kind of thing where I'm like,
well I want this to work so I want to
like put the effort in and get it going
and see how far I can push it.
Um,
and to get a shout out you kind of have
to be putting the work in already.
Like he wouldn't have shouted me out if
I wasn't doing two videos a day at that
point anyway.
Was there a point where you're getting
feedback and you're like,
oh shit,
they like what I'm doing cause I
remember I had a moment like that where
you're like,
oh fuck something.
I'm doing something right.
Do you remember a specific moment?
Yeah,
I think it was fairly early on.
People obviously like the accent a lot,
but they like the energy and the
enthusiasm because you kick it up at one
point were,
I mean cause like you said that you took
the six months and you really focus on
your content.
It was just something you changed where
people were like,
oh that,
that's good.
Do more of that.
It was just a case of being more of
myself because at that point I was
trying to imitate like the metrics and
the Felix to everybody else who was kind
of doing let's plays at that point and
then after that was like,
well I'm not going to get anywhere from
somebody else that already has a
channel.
So I just started being more of who I am
and talking honestly and saying,
yeah,
that sounds really healthy dude.
Fuck.
I guess being yourself not to take away
from it.
I'm hugely grateful for the shoutout
Felix stage and I'm really glad that it
happened and I would never take that
back.
I just think that there's some
misconceptions on the line of what that
did and that's why everyone's like,
you need to do a shout out competition
now because Felix did one,
I can see it being a little frustrating
of being like you owe everything to this
one shot.
It's like,
well that's really not what happened.
Yeah.
And even Felix for like recently came to
me,
he was like,
do you want to like delete those videos
off our channels anymore?
Cause like it's like still a whole thing
cause he knew that people were like
shitting on me for that and say like
you're only popular because of this
thing.
So that's so insane.
That's so ridiculous.
Keep it there.
It's a piece of history that,
but no,
it's good.
Yeah.
Live.
You'd go and watch it.
You can see it's like he's not like you
need to go subscribe right now.
Play your video.
It was like check the guy out and he,
he,
I think he was supposed to do the shadow
of competition and then he kind of
forgot about it and then he did it
really quick cause he came back from
somewhere and then that's why he's face,
this isn't even on it cause he just
recorded the thing with his microphone.
Unbelievable man.
Cutie Pie.
You want a guy has on another level.
Yeah.
And he's still five now.
The way we talk about like burnout and
shit,
he still posting every fucking okay.
I don't know how he does it.
He must be deeply,
deeply,
deeply damaged and miserable,
but he seems really well adjusted.
That's what is the optimum?
We're all damaged man.
I mean he changes up as content enough
to keep it fresh for himself.
So yeah,
I don't like how well adjusted he seen
it.
I don't like it at all.
A psychopath and he doesn't care about
anything.
That's what I like.
Podcasts.
Felix is a cycle.
What's with the top?
What's the top of the morning?
What's going on there?
Where'd that come from?
Oh,
well if you go back and watch an earlier
video,
my intro used to be hello all you
beautiful people out there helping them.
I was like,
I wanted to,
yeah,
I wanted to have like somebody else's
voice.
Mine.
I hated my accident.
I didn't like look at,
they sell for anything.
So my earlier videos have a different
intro,
different voice,
no face cam.
And then later on,
like during that time I was like,
well I don't really like this.
And they started showing my face and
then everyone thought I was American
pretending to be Irish because me doing
that for probably sounded kind of
Americanized.
And then I was like,
well I want to show people I'm Irish.
What's the most Irish thing you can say?
And then an episode of friends,
Monica Says Tapa Dot Martin and tea
that's very Irish that it was like,
okay,
I'll be as Irish as I can be in the
first five seconds of my video,
just as a joke.
That's fucking,
and then people resonated with it.
I was like,
if you don't make the first five seconds
of the video,
you're not going to like the rest of the
fuck off.
So the great firewall,
that's interesting.
Sorry.
So I can't really take credit for
friends.
Lots of generations of Irish people came
up with that.
How do are you famous in Ireland?
Because like do you get recognized more?
You're the biggest youtuber in Ireland.
Do you get recognized?
Do people know about you in Ireland?
Yeah,
they do.
You say it like that.
Why do you say it like that?
Cause when I was living in,
I was living in a small town that had
like 15,000
people in it.
Yeah.
Like every time I went outside it was
like get ready as I was like six seven.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Cause just cause it's a small town and
people know what you live there and
people are just out and about anyway,
depending on at the time of day,
obviously I want to have green hair.
It was just a lot more you bond over
payment in Ireland.
You're Bano famous pretty like household
name honorary president of Ireland.
Pretty much.
I think it probably president level.
Well what's,
it's funny cause a thing that happened
awhile ago was they did a list of the
top 10 most influential Irish people in
like a tabloid paper.
It meant nothing.
But at number 10 was the president and
nine was Bano and then I was next to
you're done,
you're old news.
So it was really fucking weird.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's not,
that's,
that is not a horn was right after me.
I was like,
Hey,
no.
How do a Irish people feel about,
about you?
Are they like,
are they like,
hey,
one of our boys?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
what's the mentality like,
hey,
it's very divided.
Religious people can be the most passive
aggressive people you'll ever meet.
They're super friendly and they're
great,
but they'd be like,
anytime somebody would see like the
thing about Irish people,
it was like you'd see somebody like at a
person in la would see somebody like big
house in the hill and they'd be like,
wow,
that's what I'm going to work towards.
We're an Irish person.
You'd be like,
Oh fuck.
And doing well for himself,
isn't he great hill?
And then you never talked to him or
anything.
That's a really funny and so some Irish
people are like,
yeah,
he's out there representing the country.
And then those people are like,
I hate that he represents our country.
And I'm like,
I'm not representative fucking anything.
Just don't like that.
I can't even represent myself.
What,
what,
what?
That's so if you go like how much are
you going to recognize here in La is
compared to like back in Ireland?
Not nearly the same really because I
think green hair.
Yeah,
I expected the opposite to be frank.
Really?
Well I don't know because like Isla and
probably the biggest challenge Israel,
right?
Most famous Youtuber,
I don't know.
But in Israel and no one knows.
No one really knows about bald.
Well also I think it's the language
barrier probably.
Is You speaking Hebrew,
English obviously that's where we speak
to.
Oh I thought we were speaking Hebrew all
this time.
Do you remember,
was there a time where like,
cause your channel at least from my
recollection seemed to like blow up
really fast,
right?
Yeah.
Was there like a month or like a period
of time where you went from making like
you know a couple hundred bucks to like
all of a sudden your income was like
insane.
Yeah.
It went from earning just enough to like
get by each week to a point where was
able to like go right an apartment,
move out of my parent's place and just
like what's the scope of time and like a
month.
It wasn't like fucking crazy,
but I mean at the time,
yeah it was,
it was nuts.
It was like the difference between like
a hundred dollars a month to like six
and a half thousand and I was like,
I can move out.
Yay.
That is sick.
I can actually rent a place.
What were you doing before youtube?
You had a job where you going to
college?
Where did you see yourself going before
that you had this whole opportunity?
I went,
I've gone to college twice really?
So I went to college for music
production first and then like that,
it wasn't very good at it.
I played drums and I wanted to learn
more about that,
but it was all about theory and how to
fix electrical circuits and shit like
that and I didn't care.
So I left that and then it became very
depressed and miserable at home.
That's when I started youtube and then
went back to college for Hotel
Management and graduated from Hotel
College.
You did?
How many years is that?
Who it tell the call it three years.
You're a fucking hotel manager,
Bro.
Tray.
What did you learn that in?
Hotel management?
Fuck all.
You learn how horrible hotels are.
The whole time we were there they were
like,
hotels are overworked,
underpaid,
understaffed,
and they're all losing money.
And we were like,
cool,
I'll get my gym.
Good effect that so weirdly specific and
then now you can learn that.
So in in college when I was doing like
the final semester,
that's when that moment happened and I
was like,
I left college wants before I should
finish this one out and get a degree of
some sort.
I don't know if youtube is going and
that thankfully it took off cause I
don't to work in a book in a hotel.
And you were living with your parents?
Yeah.
How did your parents feel about the
youtube pursue?
I mean my parents have always kind of
been supportive almost to a fault.
They're one of the good ones.
Yeah.
Well I to a fault,
I don't think you should give them that
much credit,
but it was just the case of like
whatever I was into they would just let
me do and if I was passionate about it
they would.
Do you think if you are like now still
at 5,000
subs at home being a Youtuber,
what would they,
could they still be like do your thing
or would they be like you need to fuck
off,
push out?
I'd say they'd be fine.
DABS.
One other good one.
That's pretty interesting.
Damn.
They've been nice people.
Sorry.
You're going to open your own hotel now
all the way to the top of the morning.
Cause like you've um,
what's the first,
what's the first nice thing you bought
when you started getting that cheddar
cheese and Guacamole?
I bought an ipad mini.
That was the first nice watch game.
Grumps video is in bed.
I used to watch them every day but it
was on my computer.
I'm like,
ah,
I wanted to watch it.
I didn't have a smart phone at that
point.
I was like,
I want to watch them in bed.
So I bought an ipad mini,
it was like 600 euro.
I was like,
ah,
this is way too fucking much that
something like this.
I was like,
well,
I'll even get the use out.
And I went over like a month in my head
being like,
should I get it man?
I don't know.
Then I got a needs that every night.
Thank God I still have.
Nice.
Yeah,
you use it.
I don't use it.
Yeah.
That's cute.
It's a nice little remembering.
First thing we bought,
I remember the first thing we bought
nice was the TV and we were in New York
and New York.
I bought like a 35 inch TV to him and I
was like,
I never,
I never owned them.
We never had a duty for five years.
And I was like,
I was like,
listen,
I had a pretty good month.
I'm going to buy myself a TV.
Hell yeah.
Drop that chat around it and it wasn't
built.
You're actually,
it wasn't the one in the podcast studio
until we replaced it.
We replaced,
yeah.
You got rid of your own piece of
memorabilia.
Yeah.
Well,
you gave it to family or they give it to
who's,
who's someone took it.
Ian's got it.
I'm not upset.
I'm not sentimental until now.
You and I want my fucking tv back into
our bedroom was tiny and the TV was big.
We were in this tiny New York apartment
and I wanted a big TV dude.
I was crushing.
It was like 500 bucks by like fine.
Like it was only the bed and the TV.
I mean it's a smaller than.
Yeah,
I mean it makes the TV look bigger,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
the TV was in normal.
I look at it now.
List small.
I mean,
what's Nice as much.
This is like 65 smaller.
It was much smaller,
but like I,
we watched,
we watched a lot of hits on directs
hunter.
Oh yeah,
dude.
First Time washing that banger.
Love that show.
I thought everybody was an anime.
I say,
listen,
you've got to watch hunter x hundred
people.
Don't listen to me.
People need to listen to me more.
This is your moment.
Shouted out.
We tried to tell everybody for you
there.
Advocate.
I'm a super fan.
Oh really?
Are you,
do you,
I mean,
what's your favorite anime?
I don't know cause I had gotten into
animate like very recently.
I mean I watched like dragon ball when I
was younger.
And have you watched hunter x hunter?
No,
I know of it.
And then as a legacy to it.
But you said it like you've watched it.
No,
I know it's,
I know it's probably decent.
It's decent.
Give me a fucking break and I didn't
mean to fucking attack.
Okay,
go right.
You're told me the brony bloaty like
what do you watch?
My favorite is one punch man.
Oh,
okay.
One Punch is probably my favorite show
of all.
It's his favorite.
Like I've watched it three times and
still rewind boy,
like every week.
Every week he asked me,
do you want to watch one punch man?
And I'm like,
Oh that was gone.
And yes I have.
I don't,
you'd have to leave this table,
but I don't want to read,
watch the whole season 10 times.
I love it so much that I bought it on
Amazon again so that I could watch it
with the English dub.
So that felt newer,
cause I've watched it so many times it
wasn't shit.
No,
I loved it in English.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
I ended an English and I took some
getting used to,
but yeah,
he's in two.
Got It announced.
Yeah,
I just like it.
It's well animated.
The pacing of amazing.
Great.
It's,
it's got like the perfect show.
it's doesn't take itself seriously Ila.
It's hilarious.
Have you?
Yeah.
It's a show.
You're in the minority here.
I've watched it like three times to just
go.
Yeah.
Thanks Dan.
I'm not even that much of a super fan.
Yeah.
He,
he's in the minority of friends and this
is so perfect.
It's like,
it's hilarious that the fighting scenes
are the best I've ever seen.
Yup.
So,
well animated doesn't take itself
seriously.
Compelling characters.
Incredible action.
Nonstop thrill rides while maintaining a
great heightened sense of humor all at
the same time that I mentioned.
Great animation.
Yeah.
Well I can't wait until they come out
into like a one punch man.
It's not the best that's actually attack
on Titan.
Okay.
False.
I liked that show.
I love attacking.
It's not better than them.
I hate to admit this,
but I feel like all my favorite shows
right now or anime it's cause there's
good animals.
No,
it's like the one on Netflix now.
If the little cat girl who gets Anglo,
I haven't watched that.
I've seen.
Is that a good one?
Yeah,
I'll check it out.
It's fun.
I mean,
I saw the picture,
I was like,
I can't,
I'm not really my take my hero academia.
We're watching a dude.
I'm all caught up in that shit.
You want to get some superhero right
now?
Micro academia.
If I'm fucking,
every Saturday it's on Hulu.
I'm like [inaudible] clearer calendar.
And of course also baby.
I have to say the fight scene,
but to I don't want,
I'm not going to spoil anything but like
that epic fight scene between one of the
newer ones.
Yeah.
But it's with all my,
the villain.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
Dude.
I was like,
I've so captivated.
Yeah.
I watched that episode back to back
twice.
That's a good one.
Damn.
Any broken?
No hero fans out there know.
Um,
um,
but I love all these shows.
But hunter hunter by far,
I mean in terms of like writing and
music,
I mean the writing and that show is,
is beyond anything I've ever seen.
It,
it's like 550 ups.
That's a,
that's a bit steep.
I mean,
all good.
There's enemies like,
like a one piece I'll never fucking dare
to get into because it has like 5,000
episodes and it's still going like take
a rest.
I used to watch him to bleach and then
it was like tried nothing is a choice.
It's never getting to the end.
Give me a break dude.
I need to know that there's an end in
sight.
That's why I'm like full metal,
full metal alcohol.
Yeah,
that balance.
That's my second favorite.
I him in on that.
That was one of the first anime series
we watched and I loved it.
But I tried rewatching it recently and
after becoming a fan of like,
you know,
one punch man and,
and,
and uh,
hunter x hunter and I'm like,
don't love it as much.
The original or Brotherhood though.
Brotherhoods obviously,
you know the more cherished one.
The good one.
Yeah.
I don't know that it was a good judgment
though,
cause I think you only tried like to
like just at the beginning.
Yeah,
it's pretty slow.
I guess so.
I still think it's up there.
You know it's one of the best ones ever.
Yeah.
Did the tea,
the tea,
what's the tax rate in Ireland?
Let's get to what's really important.
It's like 15% isn't it?
It's like 12 and a half corporate texts.
Oh my God.
That's what you pay because you're
probably incorporated,
right?
Yeah.
Well I'm not in Ireland anymore.
Oh,
so you're getting fucked by UK now.
Was that a big change for you because
that Ireland has like one of the lowest
tax rates of any,
what is it in the UK?
It's probably right up there with it
everywhere else.
Like 40 or something 40 40 I don't,
I don't want to say out loud because I
can't remember it off the top of my
head,
but it's like much more.
Was that a big change for you?
Yeah.
That's kind of painful.
It's also just you have to control the
fucking paperwork of moving everything
over.
That is so annoying.
So you had to change your company to an
English company or how does that work?
Yeah,
it was just a lot of shit involved with
like creating like subsidiaries and shit
like that.
Just to make sure everything was above
board.
I have fantasies about paying 15% tax
rate.
I wake up like,
oh my God,
I texted only 15% I'm like,
no.
It was just a dream.
Oh here.
It's like closer to 15 in California.
Just a,
if you want to move to La,
you can be paying 50% okay.
I'll keep that in mind,
man.
Start saving up now.
They have enough of that tax bill.
Can't wait to pay that army bill.
I mean 50% that's what you're facing
here.
I mean that's,
that's what's ridiculous about it,
right?
It's because we,
you don't really get much.
Yeah,
yeah.
No college and health care,
that's a whole rabbit hole.
That's the thing,
because my editor is from Sweden and
everything over there is free.
So like free healthcare,
free education,
you get paid to go to college.
I don't get all these,
other than that,
it's like a conservative talking point
here.
Is there like a socialism never works
and it's like,
what are you talking about?
Scandinavia is like a utopia.
I mean it works out.
The social,
the social programs,
it's not a shit hole country.
No,
apparently no far.
I mean,
no,
I wouldn't say so.
But um,
rmn well you probably don't want to get
into politics political they made,
cause I'm not thinking about politics
and I'm just a person experiencing like
paying so much taxes,
but you don't get anything.
I don't know even why it's gotta be so
political.
Well,
it's like,
I mean,
I guess it's something that I've been
thinking like trump wanted to have $100
million military parade in DC and
meanwhile actual veterans aren't getting
healthcare.
It's like what the fuck?
Meanwhile it's like you always get this
talking point of like,
how are you going to pay for it?
You say you,
it's a very liberal talking point that
you want,
you know,
healthcare and college tuition free to
whoever wants it.
And they always say,
how are you going to pay for it?
It's like,
Bro,
you,
how are you going to pay for your $100
million military prey space force?
Damn.
Let it out,
man.
You know,
speak your truth.
How are you going to pay for anything
spilled?
I political worry.
We're in debt.
Trillions of dollars.
What do you what?
Who's paying for that?
I don't know how I could figure it out
now.
They figured.
Well,
the truth of the matter is that when you
have social healthcare,
it's actually cheaper than what the fuck
ever.
Where have we have now?
Because like,
well anyway,
you're gonna have to drop a soundboard
on now to break that 10.
It's true.
Maybe not the right one to drop.
So you get here.
We will speak.
Got It.
Let's do you have a lot.
Are these new,
you just got your stream decks.
Alex Jones.
I'm here.
This is my favorite.
You're going like this?
Yeah.
Oh,
you can just intersperse them the curb
theme every time I die in fortnight.
That shit.
Really?
Yeah.
You let carb.
I haven't watched a whole lot of people.
What I've seen is good.
Yeah,
that's great.
Do you watch Seinfeld?
No.
Is it popular in Ireland?
It's popular everywhere.
It was like it came right
before my time and then growing up
friends was like the big thing.
Yeah,
so I kind of missed the Seinfeld boat,
but I do want to go back and watch it.
It's,
I recommend it forced a few episodes on
curved Daniel.
Definitely in like Seinfeld.
You.
How many tattoos do you have?
Do you have just one?
Just the one.
I want to get a second one.
This here.
I'll show the people here.
You like massive blood.
One Tattoo,
right?
We have it right.
You actually can show it.
Yeah.
You don't need a picture here it is on
the TV.
If you guys with directly or have you
guys look on the TV here.
There it is.
Wow.
It's so the likeness.
Uncanny.
What?
What does the game mean to you that you
are so enthused about this game that you
were,
you wanted to tattoo it?
What is it again to people like me with
don't know bloodborne.
Dan's a big fan of it apparently.
Yeah,
so what I've always kind of been from
software and the people who make it and
I love dark souls.
Two,
three demon's souls and this,
and then I always wanted to get a tattoo
anyway and it was in my head was like,
what the fuck am I going to get?
Nothing.
Reading means a whole lot to me.
And then this,
this I decided to get because you have,
you don't need to know a bloodborne is
to know what this is and I think it's
just a cool design anyway.
I was like,
well I want to make the leap and get
something and then it's like my second
favorite game of all time and then it's
first shadow of the colossus.
Well let's get a fat fucking tatted on
your face on my face.
While I don't know you love it that much
more.
I've never played that game,
but it looks amazing.
I've seen footage.
It's so cool.
Nice.
I played when I was a teenager and it
blew me away.
When you poop,
do you uh,
do you wipe forward or backwards?
Front to back.
So you boast about you go like this?
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you do?
Listen,
it's a whole thing,
but no,
I go fucking,
I go back to front.
I go under the balls and I,
and so it's really a point of contention
contention here on this podcast,
but it fucking weird shit into your
balls,
bro.
Aye.
What if you drag shit up your ass crack?
Then you can just keep wiping,
but do you yeah.
Well that's weird.
I have control dog.
I'm weird.
You Street shit up your ass crack all
the way up called control dude.
All the way up the back.
Leave a good sense.
Or do you uh,
use baby wipes?
No.
You go all dry.
Yeah,
I mean if there's a,
if it's a messy situation,
there's a sink nearby,
you know,
was just like Dab it up with your hand.
No,
the toilet,
the toilet paper because it's wrong with
it cause I,
well because I can't wet toilet paper
cause it my assholes Harry and it sticks
to the hair and gets dingleberry's.
But you have a cloud.
Asphalt sounds like a fucking you
problem man.
No Man shall pass.
Do you shave your ass?
I mean a little bit.
Yeah,
I'm going to keep things but
how do you schafly shave your asshole
would very precise tools.
What?
Tell me cause I'm,
I'm man that needs to learn.
I don't know man.
I don't want to like,
like dollar shave club.
Could you use a racer?
No,
not that fucking weird.
That's what I'm concerned about because
I don't how old baby you,
you,
you manicure with scissors or what?
I mean,
whatever.
Whatever gets the job done.
Whatever's in the house.
Hedge clippers,
lawnmower.
Huh?
You know,
so you don't use a razor and get it in
there.
No,
Jesus.
That's what I,
that's what I imagined.
But the thing is,
even if the assholes are short,
I feel like,
well I feel like it's still good stuff.
I,
well I don't,
the situation is clearly different.
What was it?
I could just be lying right now as well
and dragging you down a rabbit hole.
You're not lying.
I'm not lying.
No,
I'm here.
Yes.
Shaven.
Just the thought.
Never crossed my mind.
To be frank with you.
I know.
I actually had guests here who they
shaved their asshole too to help this
situation down there and I'd have to
think that would be a huge life
improvement for me,
but I don't really know how to get in
there.
Do you put a mirror on the ground?
Do you lay on your back and look at your
asshole in the mirror?
I mean,
how do you do it?
How'd you get the,
how do you get the vantage point?
I think you just guess.
You guess it's like,
what?
Like this?
Do you have a fucking prolapse ass?
Oh,
but like hemorrhoid sticking out.
I don't know.
It just seems like a more delicate job
than just,
you know,
blindly go and lady get it watches.
Wow,
that's fucked.
Just take a page out of Philly ds book
and just jump into it.
Just get right into it.
I don't think that's what he was
talking.
It probably is.
He seems like a clean,
I'm fascinated by this because
everyone's said this is something that
you know,
generally isn't talked about,
but everyone has really,
no,
we need male role models right now.
Half of my audience are freaking out
right now.
I didn't need to know.
Yes you did.
Fanfic just got a whole lot weirder.
Atomizing it after shave each other's
asses.
I didn't say that.
Oh God.
It just give people ideas.
Um,
one thing that I did pick up from having
this conversation I'd like to pass on to
you and actually some of our listeners
who are probably waiting for updates,
metamucil,
have you heard of that?
It's a fiber supplement made up this
thing called Piss psyllium husks and it
really tightens your,
your shifts.
Yeah.
And so I found that it's really,
it's been a great,
really great,
beautiful thing.
Take a pop with a couple of those in
your mouth.
This fiber,
it's supposed to be anyway.
Farber fiber.
It was just balanced.
You wouldn't be,
I'm slurry call it.
How has it helped?
I mean sure,
but it helped.
It helped euros all the time.
And Uros you're not from la?
No ghost.
I'll call it Tulsa.
We shouldn't like a dream burger and
burrito salsa note.
It's also,
it doesn't help you do what Irish people
fuck with spicy food?
No,
actually I do.
What do you mean Ireland?
Like what's the dish that like people
fuck with their yeah,
we don't,
we don't really have like traditional
dishes out.
Oh,
we to cover that down.
I'm going to lawsuits in here.
Yeah.
Are we covered by insurance?
I think.
I don't think we are.
I'm bleeding everywhere right now.
Um,
no.
Like lamb stew is like a big thing or
shepherding my lamb stew.
That sounds Dank.
It's pretty good.
Really fatty cut of lamb.
Yeah.
What?
Shepherd's Pie.
I'm not sure I've ever had authentic
minced meat with certain light.
We've had that over like mashed
potatoes,
mashed potatoes on top,
on top.
Cook it.
So it's like crispy on top pie crust on
the top.
No,
that's American.
That's something that they would do in
America.
Like guilty for us.
I'm going to add,
pick it up and off.
Then it's a melted cheese on top whipped
cream right now.
I'm hungry.
That's what you get the shitty ass all
the time.
Exactly.
But I need help.
I need help.
I'm not kidding.
And let me tell you what,
I'm not paying for anybody.
Aren't you supposed to be his carer?
Fuck this shit in Ireland.
Like a and made of intestines and show
like blood put and you fuck with blood
pudding.
Hell yeah.
Black,
black pudding.
I have blood that you eat basically
spices in it.
She's good tank.
It's healthy or unhealthy.
Oh,
woefully unhealthy.
I'd say full of salt,
but it's so good that it's worth it.
Yeah.
Put It on a,
it's like a four Irish and say,
think of a better,
like more enticing name.
What was called black pudding.
Oh,
it's not blood pudding.
No,
that's,
that is what it is.
But we don't call it though cause no one
would eat that.
Yeah,
that sounds so weird.
I mean,
you eat sausages,
which is lined with like,
no,
I'm done.
Yeah,
I liked it.
Um,
do you have?
Well,
we've got pretty much everything sorted.
Okay.
We got through the,
the sodomy,
the firies,
the politics.
He dropped a fortnight in there,
right?
Yeah.
I'll put four,
nine.
The thumbnail.
We talked about Logan,
Paul and therapy.
Logan.
Paul.
We talked about the suicide forest.
Yeah.
Who's going to win that fight?
Drop that in there.
August 25th we didn't talk about that
now and then I'll click bait.
I have talked about,
oh we did this podcast today.
Not Today.
Who Do you think's going to win?
I think Logan's going.
When is he taller?
Does they have a longer reach?
What makes you think that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's taller.
He just seems like he,
he's bigger.
He's probably way more ways,
more like no case.
He's like stacked and everything and
he'd got into great shape.
But watching him fight Joe Waller who
was like,
well you only one cause joe didn't
really fight.
I haven't,
I haven't seen that actual flight.
So that would be good to inform my
opinion.
But a lot of times in boxing and
fighting in general,
the bigger guy generally wins.
That's why you have weight classes,
but these guys are probably not in the
same way.
I don't have to Tyson Tyson,
but they were in the same way class.
He was heavy.
It was,
yeah,
that's true.
Right?
Yeah.
But Tyson was also like a fucking
monster.
I just think just physicality will win
out.
And Logan used to do like wrestling in
college and high school and stuff and so
I've always leaning towards case I
simply,
because he had already had a fight
maybe.
But from what it sounds like not that
valuable of experience,
but what I do think is that it's going
to be fairly boring cause they're not
professional fighters is going to go the
whole length.
Nobody's going to get knocked out and
somebody's going to win on on a
technical one.
Yeah,
it's going to be,
it's going to be best.
Oh we were wrong.
Hopefully someone gets like,
mommy and I'll wash the,
I'm gonna Watch the highlights.
I'm washed the fuck out of the
highlight.
Or you're not going to get to $10 pay
per view.
Is it only 10 bucks?
I thought it was like 11 days,
$10 paper.
Paper view doesn't pay the bills.
Come on.
Why is that so a lot.
100,000
people watching.
Yeah.
They're going to charge more than that.
I honestly have no idea.
I didn't know what's going on with that.
Um,
yeah,
well fuck that.
We should just put money into a pot and
see who wins that pays the bills if
you're good at it.
Yeah,
so we've pretty,
yeah,
I mean we've,
we've really covered every single thing.
I was wondering that people are very
religious in Ireland,
right?
Yeah.
Are you religious?
No,
I haven't been religious since I was
like 12 I used to be an altar boy
though.
Really?
What happened?
Did you just like,
I mean,
was there something or you're just like,
Eh,
not for me.
Yeah.
God got,
it was so weird.
It was such a fucking woke 12 year old.
Really.
I was like running down the field,
playing around and then I just thought
to myself,
I cut very existential was like,
what if it's not real?
What if God is not up there?
What if God is not one of us.
And then I like went down this rabbit
hole and I was like,
I don't think I believe in God anymore.
On by on your own,
kind of do your own thing.
Are you,
is your family religious?
Yeah.
Oh,
am I gonna do they think about your,
are you an atheist?
Would you consider yourself an atheist
or an agnostic or you just not,
yeah.
What would you say?
I'd say more agnostic.
More for the optimism of it.
Sure.
We're atheism is like,
no,
nothing exists.
Yeah.
Like gnostic is like something might
exist.
Who knows?
Opened up my eyes to it.
Yeah.
God isn't real.
Changed my mind.
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
how does your family feel about the,
your godlessness put my hedonism.
My parents never really cared.
They didn't mind.
They went to church and everything,
but I never told my grandmother that.
I didn't believe in God because she was
very,
very religious and,
and I'd never knock on anybody who is
like,
if you want to do many of their,
it gave her like great peace of mind and
she felt a lot closer to things in her
later years,
everything so fantastic.
But for me it just,
it didn't really make sense in my head.
Just say.
Hmm.
Is there a growing like a among younger
people,
that's probably a growing attitude
though,
right?
100%.
Yeah.
I mean we're just legalized abortion
there at a couple of months ago.
Right.
And that's cracked just a couple of
months ago.
Ironically,
America is going to,
going back to making it illegal.
I mean that's huge for Ireland and like
same sex marriage is allowed there now.
And that was a recent development too,
right?
That,
yeah,
that was what that was within the time
I've been doing youtube,
I remember that.
Maybe like two years ago.
Hmm.
Great.
I don't know.
The moving forward.
The whole world is so weird thing that,
well,
it's not that word.
It makes sense,
but it's just interesting.
Hmm.
Okay,
but can we talk about religion?
Talked about,
well,
sex life shit.
How's yours?
Yeah,
let's not get into it.
What does that mean?
Now I want,
now let's get into it.
What's your relationship like with your
parents?
Fine.
Oh,
not bad,
huh?
It's fine.
It's great.
My parents,
whenever they come back,
they're fine.
It's not like that.
How's your sex life?
I'm talking about my fucking,
since you brought it up as a fucking
meme,
you have a girlfriend,
right?
Long Story.
I get it.
Huh?
Do you have a girlfriend?
Right.
Stop swords.
She's a white woman as a wife.
Girlfriend now as well.
Yeah.
No,
I don't have a girlfriend.
I don't have any time.
What?
I don't have any,
I mean together,
although I immediately fell sourcery for
me to have a side girl.
Yeah.
I have to work quite impossible.
I'll also add to the mix that nobody
wants to fuck that maybe would make it
even more of a feed there.
There's some people out there.
I'm sure some people in the comments
right now being like,
I would definitely fuck you.
Yeah,
they're not out there.
I'm telling you like married like very
public publicly and you,
so you think people would want to fuck
me.
Shit.
Maybe fanfic.
It's an idea.
I write one for you.
That'd be sick.
What about me?
But I'll just in general I'd write one.
Actually I did it.
I forgot I,
I noticed you sit in a video that 2017
was the worst of your life.
That really stuck out to me.
I was like,
Whoa,
I don't know if you want to talk about
that,
but I was really curious like what was
going on in 2017 there's a lot of stuff,
a lot of like youtube stuff and
everything and trying to figure out what
I wanted to do.
Like that thing of like climbing the
hail and then getting there and be like,
what else can I do it now?
Yeah,
I'm feeling very aimless.
There was a lot of like,
like stuff with in my life that had
changed very drastically.
A lot of friendships,
a lot of stuff like that that had just
gotten very weird.
And then by the end of the year I was,
I just felt so drained and exhausted and
miserable.
I didn't really know what was going on
and that's why the whole like pma things
started cause I,
I was going into this year,
I was like I'm going to make it
positive,
I'm going to change my mentality and
just work towards a better me.
So what does PNA mean?
Positive mental attitude and what does
that,
it's just something that kind of gets
thrown around to be like keep it
positive mental attitude and to me it
was something that I could just keep
saying to like remind myself to be
happier.
Like a mantra of something like that.
Not to,
not to dwell on the bullshit that was
happening that really meant nothing in
the grand scheme of things.
And then because I kept saying a whole
bunch,
my audience obviously picked up on it
and then it's become like a whole like
movement on my channel.
I was like,
okay,
I can not,
we can wear it around with me.
So you,
you,
you feel that you were,
you were able to willfully change your
attitude by just consciously forcing
herself to be more positive?
Not exactly cause I don't,
I don't think that's healthy to just,
and that was the whole point of it.
I was worried that people would be like,
yeah,
just go out there and be happy.
If you're happy then nothing gets you
down.
So what bullshit.
I appreciate that it's more complex than
it's about like it's going to sound so
hokey.
It's about like trying your best to get
to a positive mudding in the work to get
out of the hole.
So for me it was a lot of like starting
to go to therapy,
like reflecting on things,
easing up on my work life and just
having a better balance with my mental
health and coming to terms because for
the longest time I was like,
everyone sees me as the positive person,
but if I show any sign of like I'm sad,
then I was worried I was letting people
down.
And then that creates anxiety and things
like that.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm just going to be open,
honest cause I'm going crazy.
It's gotta be a burden to be like that
positive,
happy,
energetic guy.
Yeah.
And then especially when you have people
coming to you and be like,
man,
there's like no drama on you and you're
so happy all the time and people have
nice things to say about you all the
time.
And that's just way too much pressure
for any person.
And it's not true.
I'm don't feel like I'm not that all the
time.
No one's perfect.
Yeah.
Um,
so then just don't try to re reconfigure
my brain again as you get to a better
place.
And because it was a lot of stuff that
was like,
that meant nothing.
It was a lot of very tiny things to kind
of build up that mean nothing.
And then you get miserable about them
for no reason.
And then because I have so many people
that come to me talking about their
mental health all the time,
I figured that let's do something better
with it.
That's what we start doing,
the monthly charity streams and then
this is like the Hashtag for it every
time and try and turn it,
turn some turn things into a positive.
I think trying to work to a better life.
God bless you.
I not,
I'm an energy to be miserable,
sadly.
No,
I'm in the same head space.
You are.
I really liked what you said.
It's not about like,
Hey,
I'm happy now.
Yeah,
it's about you have to make,
you have to like make the changes that
you know you need to make to get there.
I think a lot of youtubers suffer with
that because they have everything they
need technically or everything they've
always wanted.
They haven't,
you know,
it's like why?
It's like I have no reason and worst of
all,
a lot of the fans are people watch or
like very judgmental about like what the
fuck that you have to complain about and
that's the thing when your,
when your finances are taken care of and
you're your own boss and you're doing a
job you love,
all that's left is emotional issues.
All the things that you have left to
worry about or stuff that's all in here
and your brain has a lot of shit to you
that is not useful at all.
And on top of that,
millions of people have an opinion about
you that you've never met and you have
to be their advocate for their mental
health a lot of the time as well.
And keeping,
making sure they are entertained and
keeping a check on them and making sure
people are okay.
And that's why like after awhile it gets
you.
But yeah,
it's nobody can go out there and just be
like,
okay,
I'm going to be happy today because
you're a fucking psychopath if you do
that.
Yeah.
Um,
but as long as you're trying,
like if you have a shit day,
it's fine.
Sit in Shit Day,
allow yourself to feel shit,
get it out of your system and move onto
the next day.
If that shit keep going.
If you have a shit month,
a shit year,
keep going.
Eventually that day will arrive where
you're happier and it all like,
that's the thing.
Everyone always says that people get
bullied in high school and then they
grow up and it's like,
yeah,
that really meant nothing.
Did it?
Yeah.
It leave some scars if it's bad enough,
but then at the end of the day it's
like,
no,
you kept going,
you kept fighting and you're at a better
place in your life.
God bless.
I love it.
No,
I've been,
I've been seriously,
I've been like,
I've been legitimately depressed for
like probably two years and that we're
just now I'm starting to like address it
and that's part of why we're not posting
videos on each three because we were
just doing too much shit and I was like
working every day and like it was
getting between me and Isla and you work
from home and hobbies.
Yeah,
exactly.
Your free time and you're leisurely time
are mixed up cause you were from home
and it's just so bad.
Yeah.
You know you can only take it for so
long before you're like,
I'm just going to have,
I'm just going to disappear forever or
I'm going to address this.
And that's the,
I think that's the problem with
youtubers is that when you're on that
treadmill and you're constantly working
towards it,
you feel like if you fall off,
you're never gonna be able to get back
on again.
It's really not true.
No,
it's not.
And you can see channels like Shane
Dawson who was,
had like huge popularity a few years
ago,
kind of,
he didn't disappear or anything,
but it's definitely not.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I know.
It's huge.
Again,
I mean the biggest he's ever been,
same with Philly d he was big,
went down,
that was huge again.
And the one that's,
well those guys stayed active.
The one that always blows my mind is
John Tron.
Like he doesn't even fucking post a
video for a year.
You know what I mean?
And he comes back and everybody's still
there.
They'll excited for content.
So it's very much that that myth has
been busted.
Yeah.
And that's why a lot of more youtubers
are talking about it now cause they feel
like they can take a break,
but I also take a break and it is really
hard to get back to it.
Yeah,
that's one thing that like when you're
in that treadmill,
uh,
not to chase when you post a video of a
week,
or at least we used to do once a week,
it's Kinda like,
it's just the routine and then once you
break it,
it's like even harder to get back to it.
I feel part,
the problem for us is that you're always
chasing like a feeling or a time of like
how it used to be.
Yeah.
Instead of just embracing like,
all right,
shit's different now.
[inaudible] you know,
I didn't mean that's the same for the
audience.
The audience are still chasing the old
use.
Yeah.
And I think they either mature with you
or they leave and shit all over you.
Yeah.
So you gotta just,
I mean,
you've been doing it for how long at
this point you're not even the salons
when you were five years.
Yeah.
Every person changes like every three
years.
So yeah.
So I think part of what's really
important for us is just to be like,
okay,
that that air has done like as a new,
it's a whole new era now because we
keep,
we've always been like,
oh man,
I can't do this anymore,
but okay now I really needed to get back
into doing that again and then it's just
like this never ending cycle.
Yeah.
Let's talk about finding balance and
stuff that makes you happy outside of
your channel as well.
That was like,
that was like the thing talking to in
therapy I realized that I don't do
anything outside of my channel.
I don't do anything like physical.
Everything's,
everything I do is mental.
Even if I play video games,
it's still keeping your brain on.
You need something to let your brain
shut the fuck up every now and then.
That's something I've been thinking a
lot to something.
It's like a whole,
you need a wholesome activity to do.
Just distract your sending the fucking
real world like what do you do?
Do you have any hobbies outside of work?
In Games?
Now that I've come here,
I've just been hanging out with people a
lot more like living in Brighton.
I hadn't left my house and like two
weeks cause I don't need to write,
I have to keep,
my video is going and then when I came
here I finally had people to hang out
with day to day.
They've just been hanging out with
people all the time,
but it's just cleared my head
completely.
Nice.
Well not completely,
no,
no ever fully clear.
But yeah,
compared to what it was,
I'm so much happier and then it makes it
easier to get back into your videos and
if you hate doing it the way you're
doing,
then that's a sign that something has to
change.
Your schedule changes or your
methodology changes or what you're
actually doing changes.
And the bottom line is if you're not
happy doing the old version of you that
the audience wants,
then it's not worth doing.
So you might as well do it.
You might as well just do what makes you
happy.
And if the audience leaves,
they leave.
If they stay,
they stay.
You got to make yourself happy first.
It's a tough pill to swallow,
but it's the truth.
Hmm.
And something,
a lot of people don't want to swallow.
Cut the tension.
Now we've really talked about everything
we really have except one
ghost stories.
Fuck yeah.
Do you believe in ghosts or Ufos or
anything paranormal like that?
I want to,
I'm too rational.
I don't,
it's fine.
It's a weird thing.
Like we,
we have a habit of asking all of our
guests if you have any ghost or Ufo
stories that sometimes the answers are
quite surprising,
but a lot of times they say no and
that's the end of it.
Okay.
So you were full story.
I mean not really a alien Ufo,
but one time I was out when I was like,
well no,
like eight to 10 years old.
I was out in my backyard in Ireland and
we were all outside very late at night
in Ireland.
You can see all the stars because
there's not much light pollution going
on.
And then all of a sudden my friends were
talking and I could hear this like
almost like a jet engine sound and I
kept getting louder and I like looked up
and there was a star in the sky that
just got like whiter and brighter and
then vanished and all of a sudden the
sound was gone.
And I was like,
that's a,
I was an alien dude.
I just saw an alien.
Huh?
How old?
Real eight.
Nine.
Did they see it?
No,
and I feel like a lunatic thing.
I'd love to do that.
That's been a,
that's cool.
Were you guys here like the missile went
off that day and the gentle marbles and
I can fill in where the ones that
somehow like capture that moment.
Did you see it in the air?
Actually,
no.
I just saw it all over the news.
I think we may have been in New York at
the time,
right?
Oh right.
But it was,
it just turned out with some missile
tests,
some shit they didn't tell him that you
want to see when you go outside.
Do you believe in ghosts and aliens?
Don't believe there's aliens visiting
there.
Yeah.
I don't believe in ghosts.
I believe there's aliens.
They're out there fucking slamming away.
Yeah.
Fucking microbes going at it,
you know?
But I don't think they're visiting the
earth.
I mean,
why would they want to?
I don't know.
Who knows?
I might just,
if they visited the earth were,
where do you think is like the worst
place they could land to be like,
fuck this.
Never coming here again.
Hmm.
That's a good question.
Because like everyone's like,
oh,
they'll come and they'll go to like dc
or New York,
like independence day or something.
It's like,
no,
it was a good end up in like,
like Zanzibar,
somewhere too much anywhere.
It's just a shit hole over,
I mean to an alien.
They're like,
what the fuck is this dance in San
Bernardino?
They land in Greenland and there was
just no one.
Yeah.
Is Weird.
Now.
This is a very reputable Burbank's the
fucking credit theory.
There's this place sucks.
There's nobody here.
Nothing's popping off at bars or
anything.
Muscle beach.
I was just like,
oh,
I don't want that.
All right.
I had a lot of fun.
Me Too.
This is great.
It was a wonderful,
beautiful time.
I'm really glad we got the chance to sit
down and talk.
How did you think it was going to go?
I thought it was going to be so awkward.
Kidding.
No,
it's not.
I thought,
I know you're a great guy.
I met you before.
Your sweet fucking guy.
Every time I meet you I'm mark.
That guy's a fucking sweetheart.
Say that.
Yeah.
So now I write my fan fiction and
that'll all shit.
I am still curious about your asshole
manicuring techniques I talk about.
I understand you're going to take that
to the grave and that's fine.
I do have a technique down.
I'll show you.
We'll take you out back maybe razors.
He got squirt your seed on like fucking
though.
Oh,
okay.
Dan Keeps telling me you guys
represent.com/h
three h three comes in black and also
heals.
Got The hoodie and also,
oh,
not wearing the extra thick hat but it's
there too.
Okay.
The great,
I did my duty.
I love them.
Thank you.
Also you can do,
I mean,
oh,
you're sold out.
Sold out,
but he can still buy them.
They're on reorders.
Oh,
pma.
Oh Eugene.
You can do a preorder.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just this batch is sold out.
Cool.
Very happy about it.
That's awesome.
And you guys,
this stuff is going great.
So good for you.
Thank you.
It's very popular.
I see it everywhere.
What the Teddy fresh?
Yeah.
See it all over my timelines all the
time.
That's really cool.
It was crushing it.
You guys should be very proud.
I'm really excited.
We have some really cool,
we've been working really hard on tape
fresh actually.
Mostly what we've been working on is
teddy fresh and we've worked on a love
designs for this winter and 2019 so it
was going to take a while for it to come
to fruition.
Yeah,
but very much looking forward to it.
Cool.
As long as you were excited about it.
That's good.
Fucking so long as you're having fun.
All right guys,
thank you so much for tuning in.
Thank you,
Sean.
Of course.
Thank you guys.
I'm glad I came out and catch up.
Catch Sean on tour at Jack Septic Guide
tour.
[inaudible] dot com or just jacks up the
guy.com.
[inaudible] dot com slash tour.
I don't know what the link is.
Oh,
there you go.
There you go.
Get some tee shirts.
Pma.
What's the website?
Same.
Want to do it all?
They really want stop.
Stop.
I got it on lock fanfiction tab there.
Yeah.
So make your favorite camps.
The highest,
the highest rated one will get a free
shirt.
Wow.
Now that's what I call it.
Positive.
Um,
what else next week.
Who we have Bert.
That's correct.
Bert Kreischer next week.
Very excited.
Great.
Wonderful.
That hilarious for crusher.
Well that's Friday.
And then we got to show Tuesday.
Yeah.
Tuesday we're going to be broadcasting
on Tuesday.
Uh,
current events,
talking about everything going on
because you need to hear what I have to
say,
cause what else?
How else are you going to have an
opinion,
right.
She'd talk about buttholes more.
I talk about it a lot.
Plenty dominant.
Yeah,
it's very hot.
All right.
That's about it guys.
Thank you so much for watching.
Have a great,
terrific weekend.
Don't forget to miss the new episode.
Uh,
my hero academia,
which is out this weekend.
Oh yeah.
I think it's going to be a good episode.
Things are heating up.
Yeah.
And um,
we will see you on Tuesday.
So my dudes,
I wish you like a blessing.
We can and all the greatest things in
life to you.
Thanks for watching.
That's all right.
Sorry.